max oder luca hey ich beantworte fragen
was ist der plan für die zukunft einfach
und ich habe schon auf insgesamt gesehen
ich habe vor vier wochen meinen bachelor
zeugnis bekommen also bin jetzt bachelor
also meinen ersten uni abschluss gemacht
ich mache jetzt eine phase wo ich nur
youtube mache ich vielleicht habe ich
das machen will wie lange ich für leute
mit mir wie es unterhalten kann und wenn
jemand sage okay youtube ist jetzt
vorbei dann mal ein master also noch nie
abschluss und dann arbeite ich wirst du
oft auf der straße angesprochen
das ist so eine sache bei mir 1 0
stressig ist leute das gibt die youtuber
die mehr sein eigenes ding machen wollen
und das ist nicht cool findet ihr auf
der straße angesprochen werden aber
generell aber ich freue mich sehr jedes
mal reich zuschauer treffer einfach weil
ich dann so sehe wer so meine videos
schauen so ganz ist die zahl jetzt 30 40
hunderttausend klicks oder 600.000
klicks ich sehe nur die zahl aber was
wirklich spaß macht ist dann zu sehen
okay das sind wirklich echte menschen
dahinter und die finde es cool was ich
mache das das beste gefühl wird hast du
schon gekotzt wegen zu viel alkohol
stimmst du dich voll auf den kopf wegen
seiner größe so mit 190 deswegen dummes
passiert eigentlich nie welche
sportarten betreibst du oder hast du
betrieben bei mir tennis thaiboxen
joggen ich habe gerade eine sehr
sportliche phase leute ich gehe so fünf
sechs mal die woche trainieren gerade
sehr viel fitness studio ich merke auch
gerade im übelsten misslichkeiten der
schulter hier auch sehr gerne laufen
also dürfen aber dass meine knie aber
nicht so spielst du auch fortnight also
ich hab mich sehr lange fordert verwehrt
was wenn man sogar auf youtube ist
freilich gar nicht so schlimm aber
importieren krasser trend war so viele
youtube also mit fordern richtig groß
geworden rückblickend hätte ich dann
natürlich auch gesagt klar hätte ich
sofort ein früher anfangen sollen weil
es außerdem gespielt habe dass mir auch
spaß gemacht hat aber so den letzten
zehn tagen habe ich gar kein vorne mehr
gespielt was würdet ihr sagen dass der
hype vorbei kann es sein dass du dumm
bist was war die sendung dass die
investitionen seines bisherigen lebens
ich bin generell nicht so mensch der so
krass auf mode achteten so gerne geld
für klamotten ausgibt aber ich habe mir
immer gedacht ich muss mir jetzt schuhe
für vier euro kaufen und habt ihr dann
einmal angezogen
falls du sido und bushido sido fahrer
überhaupt nicht dass es überhaupt nicht
mein stil ist nur so ein lied von dem
was richtig feiern das ist
er ist dass blair sogar die brown aus
das geschieht das im raum kassel sehr
viel deutsch rap am meisten gerade 17
aber ja ich finde deutsch wirklich nur
deutschland mit verschiedenen rocksong
mit katja rauszuhauen
[Musik]
aber ich würde vielleicht mal ein video
zusammen machen was meine jahre excel
verliebt nein wann kommt mal wieder was
von air supply ganz bald solltest du
schon mal ernsthaft auswandern und oder
youtube komplett beenden ich hoffe die
ganze story heraus ja ich hatte in
meiner youtube karriere in
anführungszeichen schon mal momente wo
ich gesagt habe okay irgendwie finde ich
das macht gar keinen sinn mehr man hat
auf youtube glaube ich einfach mal so
hohen phasen und down phase zum beispiel
im monat wo ich diese ganzen bios
gemacht habe da habe ich fast zehn
millionen aufrufe gemacht und dann mache
ich ein paar monate später vielleicht
ein oder zwei millionen aufrufe pro
monat und klar hat man also lieber
lieber zehn millionen aufrufe pro monat
als zwei millionen aufrufe aber unterm
strich ist es wirklich einfach so ein
geiles gefühl dass man leute mit dem was
man so macht halten kann und das ist den
leuten gefällt was man so macht
deswegen wäre es glaube ich richtig
schwer mit youtube auch zu hören was war
der grund dafür dass seine letzte
beziehung gescheitert ist der grund war
ab und zu es sich so corned beef aus der
dose so eine ganze dose und sie hat
gesagt das sieht aus wie hundefutter
nicht okay max oder yucca das ist eine
frage die glaube ich nur schwierig wird
wenn es heißt max oder meine schwester
oder max oder mein vater da machst du
meine mutter ich glaube die allermeisten
von uns die sich mit ihren engen
verwandten gut verstehen würden die
irgendwelchen kumpels oder bekannten
vorziehen dazu kommt noch dass ich mag
es einfach liebe lustigste mensch beste
band aller zeiten habe jetzt rote augen
und dementsprechend macht das was von
dieser kleinen fragen serie
ich hab mich gelernt ja und hier gibt es
noch zum erfolge von was das viel da
könnten wir noch weiter zuschauen mich
durch die weltgeschichte dackel